wenn galaxien zusammenstoßen und
verschmelzen ist das ein wirklich mehr
als spektakuläres ereignis die
interstellaren gaswolken prallen dabei
mit voller wucht aufeinander dabei
werden sterne innerhalb der beiden
ursprünglichen galaxien aus ihren bahnen
geschleudert und zudem entstehen
massenhaft neue sterne
jetzt wurde ein wirklich beeindruckender
aufnahme einer solchen galaxien
kollision veröffentlicht die einer
kamera des hubble-weltraumteleskops
gelungen ist schaut also zu wie zwei
galaxien miteinander verschmelzen und
erfahrt warum und wann genau solch ein
schicksal auch unserer milchstraße droht
jetzt bei pixum science fiction gibt es
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
schon 1784 wurde das verschmelzende
galaxien paar namens ngc 6250 entdeckt
und zwar von dem britischen astronomen
william herschel konkret befindet sich
dass galaxien paar im sternbild herkules
und ist rund 216 millionen lichtjahre
entfernt doch die form des galaxien
paares ist verwirrend und führte
astronomie teams weltweit lange auf eine
falsche fährte
deswegen gegen fachleute lange davon aus
dass es sich bei nbc 6250 um eine
einzelne galaxie handelt erst später
erkannte man dann dass dies nicht der
fall ist und stattdessen zwei galaxien
miteinander verschmelzen
der wide field camera 3 des
hubble-weltraumteleskops ist eine
wirklich ihre aufnahme von diesem
ereignis gelungen solche aufnahmen von
kosmischen kreißsaal wirklich absolut
aber dennoch kann man die beiden
stattfinden wechselwirkungen kaum
erahnen wenn galaxien kollidieren
beeinflusst dies in enormen ausmass die
entwicklung der beteiligten galaxien das
gefüge der dhünn verteilten
interstellaren materie wird
durcheinander gebracht sie verwirbelt es
bilden sich wolken um millionen an neuen
sternen entstehen
die beteiligten sterne selbst fliegen
ungehindert aneinander vorbei und auch
die planetensysteme um sie herum werden
nicht gestört dem weiten interstellaren
raum sei dank die beiden crash galaxien
verändern durch eine kollision dennoch
ihre erscheinung wenn zwei oder mehr
spiralgalaxien verschmelzen entstehen
beispielsweise sogenannte elliptische
galaxien durch kollisionen von der
galaxien sind übrigens unsere sonne
und auch die planeten entstanden und
auch sehr spannend unsere milchstraße
system steht wohl auch noch ein solcher
seitens bevor anfang des jahres hatte
ein britisches forschungsteam diesen
galaxien crash genauer berechnet demnach
wird unsere heimat galaxie in etwa 2,4
milliarden jahren mit der großen
magellanschen wolke kollidieren das ist
eine zwerggalaxien trotz des namens in
nächster nachbarschaft die aus rund 15
milliarden sternen besteht sie umkreist
unsere heimat galaxien rund 163 1999
lichtjahren entfernung und bewegt sich
derzeit noch langsam von der milchstraße
weg die simulation eines supercomputers
legt aber nahe dass sich die
zwerggalaxien zukunft verlangsamen wird
und sich wieder auf die milchstraße zu
bewegt die fachleute gehen davon aus
dass unser sonnensystem bei diesem crash
aus der bahn geschleudert wird dazu
einer der beteiligten forscher marke
scout tun während zwei milliarden jahren
verglichen mit einem menschenleben sehr
lang sind ist es nach kosmischen
maßstäben eine kurze zeit und der crash
wird fatale folgen haben das zentrale
schwarze loch im zentrum der milchstraße
wird aktiv und sich gigantische mengen
an materie einverleiben so könnte es auf
die achtfache masse an wachsen laut
mariska tun wird der crash
folgendermaßen enden
dieses phänomen wird mächtige jets
energiereicher strahlung erzeugen
die knapp außerhalb des schwarzen lochs
entspringen sterne können aus der
scheibe der milchstraße ins all
geschleudert werden also die
kugelförmige hülle um unsere galaxie die
wiederum auf das 5 fache anwachsen würde
ebenso ins halo geschleudert würde dann
wohl unser sonnensystem doch ein kleiner
trost für das leben auf der erde
in dieser zeit wird die sonne sich
bereits zu einem roten riesenstern
aufgebläht haben so dass ein leben auf
der erde so oder so unmöglich ist die 20
schönsten galaxien aufgenommen vom
hubble weltraumteleskop und erläutert
von raum zeit lockt der zukunft drauf
klicken anschauen und abonnieren
würde ich mal sagen bis dann bleibt dran